[Music]
so let's get started
hello everyone and thank you for joining
us it's 5:30 already almost and we hope
that it's going to be a great wrap-up
for your second day at next my name is
dana waste and i'm a product manager on
the g3 team and i'm business Maji also a
p.m. on the same team and visual and I
are very aware that we're standing
between you and happy hour that was
publicized just now but we promise to
make it worthwhile in the next hour
we're going to demonstrate ways that GC
apps like Docs sheets slides Gmail and
drive as well can help you close more
deals in as little time as possible and
that just means doing your best work but
a lot faster as a professional in a
sales organization you're always
striving to boost your efficiency
increase conversions sell more things
like presentations or pitch decks like
these are just tools to help you achieve
that goal similarly emailing back and
forth setting up meetings are just means
and not the end but unfortunately these
means take up a lot of your time in fact
we know that on average reps spend only
1/3 of their time selling the remaining
two-thirds are spent mainly on two
things creating presentations pushing
boxes around on a slide deck and doing
administrative work like communicating
and setting up setting up meetings
two-thirds of your time is not spent
with your clients not spend respecting
new clients and product managers on GC
likes Vishnoi means we all want to build
products that help you avoid time dreams
basically we want your time to look more
like this
we want you to spend more time with your
client less time on your administer work
to do that we actually need to
understand what your day as a sales
professional looks like so we look at
what average sales cycle looks like we
saw six main stages for the sales reps
in this room you're probably more
familiar with the
cycle than we are because we're not in
sales but we study that pretty closely
we identified time drains within each
stage everything from the perspective
stage to the stage where you close the
deal with your client these time drains
individually look small but an aggregate
they actually keep you from spending
time with your customers visual will now
walk us through the sale cycle and
explain how these three apps I mentioned
earlier would help you avoid these time
dreams to illustrate these tools we
thought we'd walk through a scenario so
I want introduce Selina
she's an account manager for Rainier
which is an outdoor adventure company
based in Seattle Rainier makes a lot of
products but they're very excited about
their new launch of a brand-new water
bottle called fresh so Selina is now
going to go and work with a lot of
clients across the US retailers and
she's going to make a bunch of content
to go pitch to these companies so we're
going to focus on what she would do in
the first two stages of the cycle here
are some things you might be busy with
she might be busy with finding the right
set of contacts to email these contacts
are in some separate CRM tool she's
customizing pitch decks for this client
she's making sure all the content that
she pitches is actually up-to-date and
she's not doing this alone she's working
with a team of people at our company
without G suite a simple task like
prospecting or leading or emailing a
client can be messy
you might delay responding to an email
when you're on the go because it's hard
to get work done and you might be
constantly context switching between CRM
tools and your email speaking of context
switching how many of you look at a
screen that looks like this every day
something was like 10 tabs open at a
time that's a lot of people okay 15 tabs
still a lot of people okay 50 tabs 5-0
any browser
you can add up always so we should we
should target happy RFS I want to know
how you get any work done so we know
that context switching and having
multiple tabs open is a real problem and
in fact they're only two real tabs that
are relevant to Selena right now and
it's these two it's our email and
processor works which happens to be a
4-0 map that's why in Gmail we wanted to
bring your CRM tools right your inbox
and as we are now installer there are
new Gmail add-ons coming and this allows
you to actually work within the context
of your email it's going to work with
cross for works and we're actually going
to open a Developer Preview soon so
watch out for that link this is going to
work on both desktop and mobile so
Selena sure can search for contacts
saved in your products account and she
can reach out to them within the context
of her email
now the next thing she's going to do is
make a custom pitch deck and this should
be easy there's probably a format that
she's supposed to stick to now in the
past you might have emails PowerPoint
templates back and forth
I hear that that's a pretty popular
product from a decade ago you might be
pinging or trying to figure out who to
ping to get this template you might be
pointed to a shared site that might be
down half the time so you're just
wasting a lot of time and all you want
to do is get started in Google Docs last
year we launched custom templates and
this allows templates to be centralized
and broken down by your use case there's
also not a lot of setup work required
once your admin sets this up trusted
users in your domain can upload new
templates and they could be easily added
and with just a couple of clicks they
are readily available for your company
to use so tsamina doesn't have to paying
her marketing team she doesn't have to
worry about finding the right sites page
and digits ready to go we're actually
going to walk through a demo of this
sure let's switch to the demo
alright so Selena is going to start on
the Google slides home page this is
where Selena to use all the pitch ducks
she's created in the past at the very
top she actually sees a list of
templates that the goal Google slides
team has made available to all customers
well it's actually compelling for
enterprise users is the template gallery
that's specific to the domain that the
person is in in this case Selena is part
of Rainier and in 2017 Rainier is goal
was to actually sell as many fresh water
bottles as possible they wanted their
entire sales force to focus on
distributing these water water bottles
with as many retailers as possible so
they went ahead and made available this
template that can be used by everyone in
the Salesforce and they can each
customize it place both based on their
clients and that's just what one flight
deck looks like but other teams at
Rainier actually provided templates for
their finance teams they also provided
for the user design team so as a Rainier
employee I can go here to the template
gallery the domain template gallery and
pick the flight deck that's relevant to
me selena is prepping for her meeting in
Chicago with her customer Gianna a
nationwide retailer so she goes and
picks the Rainier fresh 2017 50 Dec when
she opens up she sees a great starting
point with slides are relevant to
Rainier showing the mission statement
and also some placeholders that each
sales rep is supposed to fill out and
replace there are some details about the
specific opportunity that the sales rep
is looking for and even some monitoring
numbers that they need to fill in as you
may guess on Google slides we also have
a solution to scale the process of
actually customizing these templates
let's switch back to the slides
now you're probably worried as Selena is
about finding and replacing all those
placeholders so she started with the
template but she's going to go refer to
different tools again copy and paste all
this information and she's going to do
this you know every time she needs to go
make a pitch but she's going to make
mistakes and she's going to have to go
find a deck again fix the mistake so
it's very manual it wastes a lot of time
doing this so again we want to fight
repetitive and manual tasks so last year
we launched a new slide API that allows
you to do exactly this it allows you to
programmatically customize presentations
and we also launched several
integrations so one of them is processor
works this is live introduction today
and with a single click you can actually
go find each opportunity customize a
template and have a pitch deck ready to
use so again I don't want to just talk
about this let's switch to the demo
machine and then I will show you what
this looks like
all right so this is selena inside her
crm tool prosper works she has a lot of
opportunity to use that she's tracking
with her various clients she's now
working on her deal with Gianna so she
looks for that opportunity
the fresh 2017 opportunity with Gianna
and prosper works there are a lot of
things that can be tied and attached to
your client or opportunity one of them
is a pitch deck
Selena is about to start making this
pitch deck that she's going to present
in Chicago and she actually uses that
Wolff's live integration this is a tool
that prosper works built using the API
so vishnu mentioned so she selects it
prosper works asked for a template this
is a template that prosper works is
going to use to customize with Gianna's
opportunity and remember this is a
template that the marketing team made
available to the entire Salesforce a
trained ear selects it here customizes
the name of the custom of the customized
pitch deck that she's going to produce
so this is Reena her contacts at Gianna
and she has created what's happening in
the background is that prosper works is
replacing all the placeholders we saw
earlier with information that's accurate
from Selena's CRM tool so right now the
presentation is ready and saved selena
switches back
Drive and this is a presentation that
was just created right now if we open it
here we actually see that all the
placeholders were replaced we can see
the name of the company or the client
that Selena's working with her contact
tree no details about the opportunities
that were all saved in CRM tool and even
some monetary values this is pretty
powerful because in the absence of this
tool
what selena has to do with copy and
paste between prosper works and Google
slides and you would have to do it for
10 or for tens of customers and maybe
making mistakes along the way so now all
this information is ready for Gianna to
go and take this slide deck so her
customer in Chicago it's pretty slick
all right let's switch back to the slide
so to quickly recap with the slides API
your organization can make a custom
workflow that incorporates data from
several sources that can be in G suite
in a CRM tool in a third-party data
warehouse and you can programmatically
bring this all together into Google
slides now another common problem you
may have is that you're talking about a
lot of data in these techs and very more
often than not you're creating charts
and you're adding them to these
presentations so you'll have the same
charts that's embedded in all of these
hundreds of thousands of documents and
you might get a ping from the analyst
team that says hey remember when we said
we can make that bottle for $5 well
turns out it costs $800 and so that's
ridiculous obviously but the problem now
is that you've got to go find each of
these charts and all of these tags and
actually update them but really the
source of truth is still in that sheet
so what we launched last year in Docs is
the ability to actually update all of
these charts when they've been embedded
in all of these stacks and we're
actually going to switch to a demo again
great so let's see this in action so
Selena realized there is another data
point that would be so powerful for her
pitch Gianna
they've been partnering with rainier for
a while and Black Friday sales would be
a great data point to show how water
bottles sell well at their stores
so she's got this spreadsheet that was
actually created by the analyst team and
it's tracking the sales of different
items different Rainier items at Gianna
so this is a great chart that she
created so she thinks I'm going to
present this to show that water bottles
so well but of course she's not going to
present a spreadsheet in her meeting so
she's copying into her slide deck so I'm
just copying and pasting and she sees
this option an option to link the chart
what this means that the data is
actually going to stay in the sources
truth which is a spreadsheet any time an
analyst changes the number there I would
actually update the chart in her slide
deck so let me go ahead and paste this
chart place it right here let me now
pretend to be an analyst who decides to
change this number because realize that
they entered it wrong see the chart now
updating this one got bigger now they
don't need to pink everyone who used
this data ok Selena actually before she
presents you see us that there's an
update spot button pumping her to update
the data and get the most fresh
up-to-date data into her slide deck by
hitting this the chart will actually
update with all the latest numbers from
the spreadsheet yet another example
where you don't have to worry about me
making mistakes again let's switch back
to the slides
now behind the scenes Selena is doing a
lot of analysis she's estimating each
opportunity she's calculating sales
projections she's working with large
data sets from previous years because
she's trying to make these projections
for future years she has this problem
where she knows what insight she needs
to get but she just doesn't know how and
figuring out that how takes a lot of
time this is why in G suite we want to
bring machine learning and intelligence
into our products the goal here is to
really empower you with tools where you
know what you want to do and you just
know how to do it and will basically
figure out the hub one of the products
is Google sheets last year we expanded
on our Explorer tool in Google sheets we
can now suggest charts by recognizing
patterns and extracting interesting
trends in your data this is pretty cool
you can even ask quest
in language that makes sense to you this
is something that no other spreadsheet
tool out there offers you can find
features like this in separate BI
products but they're expensive and we
brought it all in just one place in
sheets so let's again demo this to
demonstrate this we're going back to
that spreadsheet with the data from the
Black Friday sales
I see the explore button is going so I
see what it has for me what we see here
are actually insights that are
pre-populated and there's a search box
that I can use to search for certain
insights I'm looking for these are not
your typical queries those are human
readable insights so even if someone
doesn't know how to write queries in a
spreadsheet they can still use it so
let's see what we have examples here I
can look for a manufacturer with the
lowest customer reading so it's pulling
here that this Dedic oh that has the
lowest customer rating and it's actually
showing me what the customer reading is
I can drop it into a slide deck or a
spreadsheet this might be a short
question with one answer but the formula
behind it is actually pretty complicated
this is what Selena would have had to
type in order to pull that insight and
that takes a bit of knowledge about how
to merge columns together and it's just
faster it's literally two clicks well
you can also see are some visualized
insights charts that Selena can actually
drop into her her spreadsheet or copy
and paste into a slide deck for example
this slide that this chart she just
created can actually be created with one
click and here it is it's pretty cool
let's switch back to the slides now we
know that the impact of this is pretty
incredible about one in three people who
use spreadsheets have no idea how to
construct a formula and you just saw
that formula I don't know how to
construct that this is a perfect example
that computers are quite good at so we
brought the power of natural language
processing into sheets so that we can
convert your sentence into the right
formula and give you the answer right
there sheet is not only product where we
brought intelligence
we brought machine intelligence to
several G suite products another recent
example is quick access in Drive which
is now available in team drives what we
are able to do is learn from how you and
your team work together and we can
understand what's relevant to you at
different points in the day or different
days in the week so given that when you
take out your phone and you open up
drive you've got a team drive we can
actually recommend content that's
trending and important our goal again is
to make it seamless for teams to get
what they need
impact again it's pretty incredible it's
being used for about to close to 40% of
file opens and for each file open we're
saving you ten seconds of time these
savings add up and obviously the biggest
key the bigger your team is the bigger
these time savings are so speaking of
teams Selena's working with a team she's
collaborating on this deck with a set of
people at her company did someone say
real-time collaboration I thought I
heard one all right so tanks a real-time
collaboration she doesn't have to send
various versions of this deck back and
forth in the past I've created drafts
and I've named it draft one draft two
draft final draft final for real no for
real this time no let's go back five
days sorry let's do that again
it's painful but this is how real-time
collaboration works in Google slides
they're working on the deck together all
at the same time making changes all at
the same time this document is super
active you'll see that they're adding
comments the resolving comments they're
creating tragic conversations it's
pretty powerful it really changes how
teams work it changes our company's work
it means that projects get completed in
days instead of weeks and you know we
want to bring this impact to as many
people as possible and they're not going
to talk more about how we plan to do
this great so as vishna said we wanted
to bring the productivity tools that we
demo today and Docs sheets and slides to
everyone even if they don't use Google
Drive what this means is that we want to
give customers access to these tools
even if they use a different storage
provider than drive how many of you here
have
worked at organizations or even
currently work our organizations where
you store your files outside Google
drive's
I know I've worked in the past that
organizations like this great well
previously if you worked at one of these
companies you can actually you can use
any of the Google Docs features we
showed you but now you can still benefit
from all these great tools while
benefiting from third-party storage
providers and their workflow tools as
well so last year we announced our first
partner in this effort in the storage
integration effort with box and earlier
at next we announced a new integration
with Citrix we're working with Citrix to
allow our joint customers for Google
Docs and Citrix to actually bring their
dogs files and store them to Citrix and
also leverage powerful workflow
productivity features like share file
and their a signature features so
Salinas organization hypothetically uses
Citrix she could work in sheets document
slides but you can still take advantage
of Citrix with built in approval
workflows like share faulty signature
all right so Selena so far has used
Gmail coupled with her crm tool with
Gmail add-on to communicate with her
existing and new clients she identified
the needs by leveraging intelligence
features and sheep she visualized these
insights with charts that she embedded
into slides and she also collaborated
effectively with the rest of her team
with real-time collaboration before she
presents the offer she is looking to
change the layout of a couple of her
slides and I'm sure a lot of you have
been in Philly on shoes
wishing pixels around you probably spent
more time doing more time doing that
making the content look good then
thinking about what the story of your
slide should be but we don't want it to
be that way in Google slides and that's
why I mean that's why we build
intelligent features in Google slides
just like we did in Google sheets so
what you can do is just drop in your
content text or visuals on a slide and
with a couple of clicks you'll have
slides that actually looks so good
people are going to think that you hire
to design agency for them and as before
let's see this in action let's switch
the demo alright so we have a pretty
good-looking slide here but I think I
have a pretty good design sense I'm
going to try to touch this up myself I
love the color grey and I also love the
color let's go with orange I think that
looks pretty good
I like this maroon thing in the corner
so I'm going to make this match that
looks critical what do you think sinner
I don't know I'm seeing a few people
crunch all right
that's Churchill let's switch to this
slide when I open the export tool you'll
see that we have an amazing number of
high quality design suggestions much
better and the reason they're high
quality is because we actually had a big
team of designers at Google and curate
and hand make thousands of designs that
go in the product and with the power of
machine intelligence we were able to
look at your slide we're able to pull
from a subset of these design
suggestions and which is one quick you
can apply it as you can see there's an
incredible amount of detail if you look
at this shape it's semi-transparent I
have no idea how to make a circle that's
so perfect and slides with a text box in
the center of it it's pretty cool I'm
going to try something here I'm going to
add another image to the slide so let's
say that we know ones add image of a dog
and a hike pretty reasonable combination
I'm going to add image and what you'll
see here is the suggestions have
refreshed in about a second and we just
a single click you're again ready to go
out on the road explore all that Vishnu
just demoed if we can switch back to the
slide was so compelling because that
really does save time we've seen that
people save two thirds of the time that
they would otherwise spend designing
slides so even if design is not part of
your expertise as a sales professional
professional you can end up with
beautiful presentations that you can be
proud of and to present to your clients
and this is all done with a couple of
clicks now we know that another problem
is to find high-quality visuals and
diagrams
in order to communicate certain messages
to your clients and here at next we're
happy to announce that the same add-on
framework that's available in Docs and
sheets today is coming to Google slides
and with the upcoming slides add-ons
we're going to bring powerful
third-party tools like balsamic lucid
chart and Adobe stock in order to enable
you to beef up these presentations and
Fitch decks and here - our goal is to
make you more productive by helping you
avoid context switching so let's walk
through how the Adobe stock add-on will
look like soon Selina will actually
start in Google slides to browse through
add-ons are available in our store and
if she was looking for high-quality
stock images Adobe stock is a great
place for them she adds the Adobe stock
add-on to Google slides and it appears
in a side nav experience like what you
see here she's able to browse through a
vast collection of high-quality images
within Adobe stock she can even browse
icons or illustrations and when she
finds the image that she wants to add to
her slide deck she has the option to
either preview it in the slide deck or
purchase it through her Adobe stock
account so now not only does she have
great designs that Vishnu demonstrated
us now she also has high-quality images
from third-party providers who are
specialized in this now while presenting
the compelling pitch decks to her
customers Gianna and various other
retailers Selina actually opens up the
floor for some questions putting a Q&A
feature in slides enables presenters to
not distract themselves by getting
questions throughout the talk but
actually maintain engagement within the
audience and because I want you to be a
little more engaged with the rest of
this talk I'm going to turn on this
feature right now alright so with a
couple clicks
I've actually turned on this feature and
you see the URL at the top of the slides
and it's going to stay here for the next
few slides you can go to this URL and
submit your questions at the end Vishnu
and I will actually see the questions
that were submitted we can see them real
time you can even vote on other people's
questions so the best questions get
uploaded now while you submit questions
we're going to continue their
presentation
now remember Selena's client Jana the
one in Chicago they're actually pretty
sold on Selena's proposal they want to
carry the state of the art water bottles
in their stores but before they sign the
contract they want to resolve just a few
issues and that will require Selena to
share a draft agreement with an external
collaborator or a client in this case if
you remember earlier in the presentation
vishnu told us about how Selena
collaborated internally with her team
each time she was able to decide what
kind of view option she wants to give
her teammate
she can give them view only rice or edit
rights so they can actually help her
decide on but Selena actually goes
through a different thought process when
she's sharing a file externally it could
be pretty nerve-racking there are some
extra sensitive information in the
agreement so Selena wants to be
conservative about what the client can
do with the file once she shares it with
them she can give them the only access
but what's so powerful in Google Docs is
that you can prevent her journal client
Gianna from further downloading this
file and forwarding it to others this is
something that doesn't apply in the
world outside cloud because the world
outside cloud you attach the file in an
email once you hit Send the recipient
can do whatever they want with the file
they can download it and send it to
other people for certain clients she can
even set permissions that expire after a
period of time so she knows she's going
to be in Chicago for a week
that's one she wants to collaborate with
her clients she can set it for seven
days only Google Docs just strives to
give you full control over the sharing
access controls that you have for your
file
and what's great is that this is
actually all done within a couple of
clicks and it's pretty slick UI so how
about we demo this switch to the demo
great so when you see here this is the
final contract that's Lina's drafted and
if you go to the sharing dialog you see
you see that she shared with a couple of
people and with just one click she can
set it to an expired within seven days
with that she's pretty confident about
sharing the fun great so let's switch
back to the slides
so once Selena shared the file her
client Gianna is ready to collaborate
and the old-fashioned way of
collaborating with file sending them
back and forth as Vishnu has explained
earlier is not the case in Google Docs
with Google Docs Selena can collaborate
with external clients in similar ways
that she she collaborates with internal
clients but we know collaborating is
different than negotiating when you're
negotiating you also want to put
suggested comments accept them maybe
also reject them
this is otherwise known as redlining and
suin you'll also be able to accept or
reject all changes at once so now that
the open questions have been answered
both parties have done crafting the
agreements it's time to sign that
contract this brings us to the last
phase of our sales cycle
now the g3 X system is full of partners
who are actually specialized and have
years of experience in certain areas we
know that there are great approval
workflows out there and e signature our
work flows out there and we want you to
be able to use them even if you use
Google Docs and one of one of the many a
signature partners is DocuSign and it's
a recommended 4G suite partner and it
has more than 100 million users in 188
countries last year the team at DocuSign
announced an android add-on and this
year here at next we're very excited to
announce that DocuSign is soon
integrated even integrating even further
with this week
we're pre announcing their upcoming
add-on in Google Docs and this is why it
will look like when you're done editing
a document you can actually kick off the
e-signature workflow in the sidebar here
in Google Docs you can specify who will
be signing and you can send Google Docs
to DocuSign at the end of the flow so to
recap what we did here is bring powerful
tools like DocuSign to you in Google
Docs and save you time and reduce
context switching and that brings us to
the end of Selina sale cycle and the
water bottle apparently is going to be
distributed in more retailers than ever
and as you saw there are real-time
collaboration tools there are some
intelligence features in built into G
suite that can help you avoid time
dreams vision and I want you to go from
here and check out even more tools that
we couldn't cover in the storm you can
find out more about G suite in the
discreet Learning Center the URL is over
there you can also hear from our G suite
customers telling them how G suite works
best for them and that would be at the
transformation gallery the URL over
there if you're more about trying things
out yourself so that's about reading on
a website you can actually pull out your
mobile device open the sheets app and
try out the sheet explore tool that
brings all of Google's intelligence
power into an app a Productivity app
like Google shoes
you